CHRIS BROADFOOT: Hi.
I'm Chris Broadfoot.
I work on the Google Maps
Developer Relations Team.
DANIEL SCHRAMM: And I'm Daniel
Schramm, Associate Product
Manager on the Google
Maps Mobile APIs.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: We recently
released updates to our Mobile
Maps APIs on both
iOS and Android.
DANIEL SCHRAMM: These updates
introduce three new features
that we want to talk about
in today's video--
map padding, marker rotation,
and flat markers.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: So first up,
let's talk about map padding.
Map padding allows you to offset
the default Google Maps
controls from the outside of the
map, allowing you to add
overlays like translucent
menu bars or side bars.
Map padding can be changed at
any time, or animated, for
example when sliding a side bar
in and out from the map.
Camera updates such as
re-centering the map take
padding into account, so you
don't need to do any
calculations about the offset.
DANIEL SCHRAMM: The next future
we want to talk about
are flat markers.
Flat markers are a new type of
marker that always stay flat
on the map, regardless of how
the camera is positioned.
This is different from standard
markers, which will
pop out from the map when
the map is titled.
You can also now rotate both
flat and standard markers
around their anchor point.
This allows you to create some
interesting flat markers, such
as compasses, which will always
stick on the map,
pointing in a specific
direction.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: These two
features can be combined to
create some really compelling
experiences.
For example, we're showing a
playback of a GPS route.
The marker's bearing represents
the user's bearing
at that particular point in
time, and it can be animated
as the marker moves
along the map.
DANIEL SCHRAMM: Those are the
cross-platform features we
have time to talk about today,
but to learn more about
platform-specific features,
please see the release notes
on our documentation.
CHRIS BROADFOOT: And stay in
the loop by following the
Google Maps API+ page.
Thanks for listening, and
we'll see you next time.
DANIEL SCHRAMM: See you.